[Música]
momento de hablar de ciencia y
tecnología en Francia 24 soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
en Reino Unido donde fue creado un traje
de propulsión Jet para paramédicos se
trata de un desarrollo de la compañía
Gravity industries y permite el acceso a
zonas donde el acceso humano común es
imposible
todo este viaje comenzó con una visión
Aparentemente ridícula de podrías hacer
que un ser humano volara no estando
dentro de un vehículo sino simplemente
agregando tecnología minimalista y creo
que Hemos llegado mucho más lejos de lo
que Jamás imaginé pero lo realmente
emocionante es que ya estamos al
comienzo del viaje hay mucho más que
podemos hacer y debido a que todo está
impreso en 3D platicamos con el diseño
casi quincenalmente Así que hay una gran
cantidad más que podemos ofrecer
el traje viene desarrollándose desde
2017 y en su última versión impresa en
3D cuenta con dos mini motores jet en
cada brazo y tres en la mochila trasera
que pueden alcanzar una velocidad de 136
kilómetros por hora a más de 3.650
metros no obstante el entrenamiento se
realiza con una menor velocidad y en
terrenos mucho más bajos
El desafío con el invierno y la lluvia
es que claramente el agua golpea la cara
y entra en los ojos cuando te mueves con
algo de velocidad
y contrarrestarlo a veces es un poco
difícil pero realmente se trata de un
artefacto muy estable que puedes
maniobrar o manejar de manera segura
el programa de entrenamiento se está
llevando a cabo en la región de Lake
District en medio de condiciones
extremas que incluyen Fuertes lluvias y
Vientos de hasta 48 kilómetros por hora
pero que son clave para que los
paramédicos aprendan las habilidades
necesarias para utilizar esta tecnología
en situaciones donde realmente tendrían
que enfrentarse a este tipo de
condiciones
vamos ahora hasta México para conocer la
historia de David zabala un niño
mexicano de 8 años con parálisis
cerebral que gracias a un sofisticado ha
podido ponerse de pie y jugar se trata
de un artefacto pediátrico llamado Atlas
2030 que fue desarrollado en España y
que tiene un costo de unos 250 mil
dólares pues México es el tercer país
tras España y Francia en ofrecer un
tratamiento Con este aparato
nos da mucha emoción de que podamos
tener el experto y podamos incluso
estarlo empleando el día de hoy para
poder lograr todo esto que vamos a claro
nos motiva mucho a nosotros como
terapeutas que vamos a poder alcanzar
muchas cosas en un futuro el tratamiento
se llama terapia de rehabilitación
neuro-robótica y las imágenes que vemos
son de la tercera sesión de David según
la responsables el exoesqueleto permite
un trabajo en tiempo
récord para el fortalecimiento muscular
mejora el sistema digestivo y el sistema
respiratorio y claramente produce una
mejoría a nivel anímico lo que tomaría
mucho más tiempo con terapias
convencionales
estamos viendo los resultados con los
niños y que queremos seguir trabajando y
potencializando y que más niños de la
ciudad y del país tengan acceso a este
tipo de rehabilitación porque todo el
tiempo estamos recibiendo a niños no que
necesitan la rehabilitación neuro
robótica y que les cambian radicalmente
la vida finalizamos en Londres para
conocer la exposición inmersiva
frameless una ex que cuenta con cuatro
salas donde las obras maestras de
artistas como cezan kandinsky Money Dalí
Van Gogh El Bosco buscan sumergir al
espectador en una nueva experiencia
no somos la primera experiencia de arte
de proyección pero lo que hicimos fue
crear una propia versión en lugar de
explorar un artista y toda su vida de
trabajo exploramos un movimiento de arte
esto nos permite elegir pinturas que
podemos representar muy bien en este
formato en un formato de proyección en
este tipo de entorno grande la primera
sala se llama Beyond reality en español
Más allá de la realidad Allí se combina
la proyección y espejos lo que busca
llevar al público a un viaje del
surrealismo el simbolismo y al post
impresionismo la segunda sala es color
innotion o color en movimiento que con
la ayuda de seguimiento de movimiento
avanzado con gestos y movimientos se
puede pintar va de la impresionismo
hasta el post impresionismo la tercera
es de World around does o el mundo que
nos rodea es la sala más grande y busca
justamente conectar con la naturaleza
pero también con grandes urbes y la
cuarta de Art of abstraction o el arte
de lobstracto quiere hipnotizar a los
asistentes gracias a un laberinto donde
te quiere flotar en el espacio al tiempo
que se mueve a través de superficies
translúcidas
queríamos analizar lo que se conoce como
abstracción pura y también teníamos
Claro que queríamos incluir al artista
femenina Gilma app porque en realidad
fue la primera artista en empezar a
profundizar en esta idea de abstracción
que se hicieron más tarde conocidas con
artistas como kandinsky O montyán
puedes ver un kandinsky detrás de mí
entonces necesitaríamos pensar Cuál es
la historia del arte que queremos contar
y una vez hubiéramos resuelto esto
podríamos poner las imágenes
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía los
invitamos a ampliar todo nuestro
contenido en la web Franz 24.com
[Música]